on this episode of travel bears I'm
taking Caroline to interactive
psychedelic art museum and I'm taking
Joe to liquid-like glassware we're gonna
make our own glass sculptures come join
us on our adventures on this episode of
travel chairs welcome to travel dares
I'm Caroline I'm Joe and we're here in
Santa Fe Santa Fe is a center for
cultural diversity and it's home to some
of the best food and artists in the
country all right Caroline are you ready
for our trip yes ready there you go okay
a surreal world awaits hmm that is a new
one Joe here we go look at this I wonder
what that means
come on I think it's gonna be something
pretty artsy it's something in the art
world I saw this place on Instagram and
I knew I had to bring Caroline here
today we're diving into Santa Fe art
scene with this non-traditional
immersive experience
[Music]
please remove your blindfold we are this
is an interactive immersive art
experience great the aah wolf is an art
collective of local Santa Fe artists so
the dream was to have a permanent space
to have an ongoing permanent exhibition
house of return or return is a new way
of telling a story that you walk inside
up instead of turning a page or queuing
up a movie you go inside and you're in
the story the best way we describe our
art is maximalist we do things big we do
them colorful we do them vibrant and we
do them so you can touch everything and
climb and crawl and go inside different
places over 70 rooms of unique different
kinds of art installations and
experiences 200 artists have now
contributed to house of eternal return
we think you'll come here have a great
time and be talking about it for a long
time to come that was awesome
[Laughter]
[Music]
come hold this alright mmm get ready to
turn up the heat
wild possibly fire where we going we'll
find out what do you think turning up
the heat means I don't know I'm thinking
something to do with going out to the
desert something involving fire those
are all great guesses so we'll find out
soon glassblowing is a huge part of
Santa Fe art culture this will be the
perfect place for Joe to channel his
inner artist and take a little piece of
Santa Fe home with him I feel terribly
hot up there okay oh geez Louise okay
all right take your blindfold off okay
I'm taking it up we are taking
glassblowing
[Music]
we're going to be making a paperweight
and blown cup and a flower today oh
sweet
over here is the furnace which you've
been introduced to this prevents it the
furnace we keep it running 24/7
it's about 2100 degrees in there yo when
you open that thing I was like oh oh ha
yeah like I'm like I'd have to get in
there do I
alright so choose your colors I like how
the purple looks so I'm gonna go with
the purple and I'm gonna do orange
[Music]
now hold it straight up and down and go
into the arch step forward I think I got
this
this pitch no can just pinch all the way
around open and close
keep pulling towards yourself yeah
all right I think we're gonna move on to
the paperweight
in 1979 I learned how to blow glass and
immediately I fell in love with the
glass eye
I love the physicality of it I love the
way the glass flows Santa Fe is awesome
because there's such a strong artistic
community here so there's a lot of
support and you can drive a half hour in
any direction and be someone really cool
and unique
all right now on to the actual blowing
part a little harder and stop now lift
that's wild
you made a flower you made a paperweight
you made a cop in a lot of you yeah now
you know what it means to be a glass
blower yeah this is it this is so nice
yeah Joe you took me to me I'll wolf and
I had an amazing time what do you think
my rating is out of five stars I know
you like arts and I know you like fun
experiences but I also know you startle
easily so I thought oh man I'm gonna
take her to me I'll wolf she's gonna
freak out this is gonna be great you
were such a pro you had so much fun you
were just totally into it the whole time
and I gotta say I was even blown away by
how much you enjoyed yourself so I'm
gonna give you five out of five okay
Caroline how'd I do in my chair today I
thought you were gonna be really nervous
by the heat but you know you really
picked up on the craft and you knew what
you wanted to design and you were really
enjoying yourself so because of that I'm
giving you a five out of five stars oh
no way
yeah we're so good at vacationing oh
thank you so much double fives the first
double fives in the history of travel
there's Santa Fe is amazing it's art of
the streets there's art galleries I mean
even in this beautiful hotel we're
surrounded by local art I love Santa Fe
so much I cannot wait for Salt Lake City
[Music]